I thought at some point that I would
have it all figured out that making
things would be a little easier but I
gotta be honest with you doesn't matter
how long you've been designing creative
block happens but it sucks every single
time if you're just joining us now I
suggest you hit pause and go back and
watch the first two videos in this
series I'm trying to redesign the
futures landing pages and to be honest
it's been easy up until now
I mean wire framing was a dream
developing the content strategy for that
one page was super super simple when I
sat down to actually create the visual
design for this page I was up against a
couple of things I kept running into
this one issue I had to use these bright
on primary colors in a way that you know
the site didn't feel like elementary
school and it's a challenge we all know
that perfection is the enemy of done but
in this case perfectionism really
tripped me up so that my struggles came
up in a couple of meetings that we had
internally and Chris suggested that I
improve my skill set I think that the
analogy that he used was that I was
using an eight-count crayons that and he
was using a 256 count crayon set so I
want to share with you my design process
here and I want to show you how this
page evolved but most importantly I want
to give you some tips about how to
overcome creative block the trick is to
have a process that you can work through
it and then you just have to show up
whatever you're struggling with creative
block try these steps one gritted out
whenever I start to grid things out I
work on a desktop art board and many
people say hey design for mobile first
and I think that's great but for me
desktops are more challenging because
there are more options and with more
options comes more decisions and more
decisions leads to almost perfection
paralysis when it comes to figuring out
where to lay things out I always try to
work with a twelve column grid and I
really want to keep the user interested
so I place the content on the page to
keep that pacing like visually
stimulating at the end of last episode I
had the grid in the wireframe pretty
close to the way I wanted it but the
challenge was I needed to start pulling
the rest of the visual design together
let's talk about breaking it down if
you're really really stuck on a UI
design project try designing these
elements first a heading 3 + body text a
heading 2 plus a sub header and body
text buttons form fields do you can see
these are these are elements that you're
gonna use over and over and over again
so why not start there start small by
tackling the small elements first I was
actually making these little micro
decisions that were iterated throughout
the entire design and this really helped
move the ball forward but even still
tying these small elements together can
be a little bit challenging and that's
when I started to do some research one
of the biggest mistakes that I used as a
young designer was to look for
references that directly applied to the
big picture thing that I was making so
in this case I'm designing a landing
page and so what I would search for when
I was looking for references is landing
page design or squeeze page design or
download page design and you might find
interesting references by searching that
stuff here's the worst case the worst
case is that you search for a landing
page design and then you find the
perfect the perfect design is always out
there and once you see it it's hard to
get it out of your head and you spend
the rest of the project trying not to to
copy that design outright instead of
doing that I suggest we research small
here's what that means I try to find
those small components on my page to
search for for this project I search for
things like CTA form block which means
call to action or block or Timeline
design or abstract shapes UI so I was
looking for those individual components
on the page that I could draw
inspiration from instead of finding this
like complete solution that
I wanted to copy directly so by being
specific I was able to find a whole
bunch of really really good references
that allowed me to pull inspiration from
for the smaller pieces of my UI once the
small components had been established I
started looking for patterns that were
in the layout and we know that
repetition is a key component of great
design and repetition is pretty easy to
achieve in UI design I mean we literally
have to establish things like site-wide
style for typography and button design
these things are natural repetition that
occurs in UI design but what I was
really looking for here were missed
opportunities I was looking for those
opportunities that I hadn't taken yet to
carry something through the rest of the
UI for example I made this cool-looking
line that connects the first paragraph
on the page to the edge of the grid and
what I noticed is that I didn't use that
horizontal line anywhere else there was
no repetition so it was kind of lonely
so what it did was I made sure to add
one more line onto the timeline part of
the landing page what this did is it
connected the left side and the right
side of the timeline so look for both
patterns and missed opportunities for
repetition so at this point all of the
bones of the page were were laid out all
the components were designed but I still
wasn't using color the right way and
I've told you guys before color is my
weakness and I was also missing these
like fun little shapes that were in the
style scape but I hadn't like pulled
them into the main design yet so I
started iterating on where to put these
shapes and I especially focused on the
header layout I did several different
versions of this a tad too much and then
I'd take too much away and then it adds
them back finally I asked around to see
what other people in the office thought
and
Matthew and Greg thought it was great
through their feedback and then enough
iterations I wound up in a place that I
was pretty happy with and this is really
where I started experimenting with
different styles of mock-ups for the
actual download
it's amazing what imagery and a use of
color does for the overall feeling of
the page but I was able to like swap
things out pretty rapidly because the
bones of the page were already designed
all the components were laid out and
really it was it was on me to start
decorating my takeaway here is get the
bones in place before you start
decorating before you start pulling in
any kind of decorative elements or
choosing your imagery for me this was
the phase that I felt like I needed the
most iteration the most revision so all
in all this was a stretch for me this
was totally outside my comfort zone
apparently I didn't have the crayons to
do this and even through that I'm
actually really happy with where we net
it out so here's the final
[Music]
just to recap those tips to recap the
process that you can use to overcome
creative block here it is one more time
one grit it out to break it down three
research small or look for patterns and
then five add subtract and iterate so
try that process out the next time
you're designing a UI or you're stuck on
something you're facing that creative
block and let me know how it goes I know
I'm not alone in this if you've hit a
wall like this before I want to hear
about it put it in the comment section
below and at the very least guys at the
very least show some love show some
solidarity for our brothers and sisters
in design who are going toe-to-toe with
creative block this week next episode
I'm gonna be developing this page web
flow and if you're interested in
checking web flow out I've put a link in
the description below it's the easiest
way for designers to make websites like
real coated with clean code websites
it's phenomenal use that link because if
you wind up signing up and I think you
will because I think you're gonna love
it we get a small kickback it's
basically like buying us a cup of coffee
so go check them out as always guys I
want you to go out there and crush it
you got this like subscribe we love you
we'll see you next time I just remodeled
my office what do you think and I think
we're done
nope that's not it creative block ism
yeah well I am just go look go see for
yourself do it go do it click the link
do it now